欢迎收听古爱,我是深梦公
本集节目由让我紧张又兴奋的老朋友
Dr.琴去赞助
18岁以下人到走廊
3、2、1
七夕情人节快乐
送情人最佳礼物
诚心推荐特斯拉
诗哒哒的诗
上次夜配玩结果涌入不少男性
听众私讯抱怨这支母汤
因为买来送给女伴
结果女伴满意路太高
反而对特斯拉吃醋了
兄弟别傻了
研究表示最令女性迷恋的性经验不是第一次
而是第一次男生用了按摩棒助性的高潮性经验
然而唯一能够再超越的就是用了特斯拉Model Socks的高潮体验
完全跟一般按摩棒不在同一个档次上
要说Model Socks有多猛
伊隆·马斯克可能不敢这样子设计
他外部搭载了吸损机制
吸填拍顶镇全部灌入
武当火力全开
更结合逆天伸缩冲刺机构有如开挂完全不留伍德
还不买来送给你的女友老婆
让这次特斯拉Model Socks成为你送的
如果他自己买了
那以后的开心报表就不是你送的了
快快按下播放暂停键
火速上Duct情趣输入代码GOOAYE888
超爽限制250抢购特斯拉Model Socks
搭配7系档期满满活动优惠到爆
确认下单完再回来
节目可以稍后停
变新的女友不等人
详情键我们资讯
有讯息的朋友可以去参考看看
那在上集跟大家分享完
关于功能性训练相关的内容之后
然后就有蛮多的地方听众
都想跑来问我说
教练是哪一个在哪里上课
這邊一併給大家一個
同一的建議
簡單來說就是你去找一下你們附近的場館
當然你可以先用一些關鍵字去找
就看他有沒有去做功能性訓練
再來就是進去找到一個
你覺得身材是非常棒的教練
接著就直接跟他上就對了
當然講這個可能聽起來有點膚淺有點悲難
但是我自己理出來的結論是這樣
當然這可能是我的結論
我尊重每個人有不同的結論
如果這個教練他的身材
就是你想要成為的對象
他就是你的理想型
當然不是說耍gay那種
就是說你想變成他
你找他學不管他教你的是不是功能性訓練
沒差啦
老實講你說真的要去解決什麼下背痛
這些姿態
他一定是殊途同歸的
絕對不是說什麼
只有某一派方法可以去解決這個問題
我相信各種方法一定都有辦法去
或多或少去解決你想要去鎖定的某一種問題
如果沒辦法解決
教練也可以幫你引進給別人
其實當時我會去發現我的教練
也是因為我自己在那邊推拉的時候
然後就發現說怎麼有一個教練
他每次都在那邊做很奇怪的東西
而且我注意到他大多數的時間
都不是在幫別人上課
他是自己在那邊狂考狂練
後來是因緣際會之下
就透過老婆知道說原來就是那一位教練也才知道說原來他做的東西叫做功能性訓練然後發現了這一切但老實講如果不是因為我有找到一個我覺得體態已經趨近於完美的人
然後想去跟他學習的話
我也不會去什麼自動自發跑去上手的功能性訓練
所以我覺得那個動機其實很重要
就像我跟大家分享
當年可能我對英文會有一些啟發
是因為我媽買給我一台iPod photo
然後這個iPod photo裡面有 Coldplay的歌
也不知道是他媽誰關在裡面的很奇怪
因為這個音樂讓我對英文產生濃厚的興趣
如果說你沒有產生濃厚的興趣之前
人家想要去推坑你說
來我們一起學英文
透過的方式什麼看課本
你一定也看不下去
所以產生興趣是非常重要
所以對我來講就是你一定要先去
找到一個非常強烈的動機
動機最好的一個方法
當然我知道有些地方爸爸非常的懂事
都會去找那種漂亮的女教練
但我自己的想法講
但我相信女教練也有非常專業非常強大的
可是我們的力量一般來講
就是比女生大
絕大多數的狀況之下
所以你當然想要找一個
就是他力量是在比你更大
他可以來cover你的
當然你如果力量沒有比女教練大
你透過女教練訓練
當然也是沒有什麼問題
總之就是去找一個
甚至可以講木牆都沒問題
就是去找一個體態好
然後非常強壯的人
然後說我要變成像你這個樣子
我覺得就可以解決大多數的問題
總之開啟第一步
需要有一個非常強大的動機
你可能可以去透過搜尋
例如說功能訓練
然後看到附近的場館
你還記得就是找一個
你覺得順眼的教練
然後就下去試看看
我覺得一定會有非常不錯的收穫
我們家已經從八里島回來
接下來又要休息幾天之後
會再一次的出國
因為沒有辦法
我覺得暑假待在家裡
跟孩子整天關在一起
還是非常痛苦的事情
就連我們可能稍微回來幾天而已
還是透過姑姑的協助
有找一些課去讓他上
不然整天在家
其實小朋友真的會把家拆掉
我們自己也覺得非常辛苦
可是跟小朋友出去玩的這段時間
真的是建立了非常多很棒的回憶
我覺得孩子是非常天真可愛的
就是我們算會在節目跟大家分享說
感覺這個傢伙好像是過太爽
竟然覺得在這種非常舒服
要價不費的度假村裡面
嫌無聊
有時候還會抱怨的東西
下次我就帶他去住親旅
但那個是我們身為爸爸
然後會想說要去試者
就讓他看不同的世界
不一樣的體驗
可能因為這樣子
他的價值觀建立會更加的完善
才會有這樣子的想法
但其實小朋友他們是非常單純的東西
他不像說你在可能20歲30歲以後
交往到的對象
因為我自己覺得
可能在學生時期之前
都還是有那種純純的愛戀
你開一台那種超破的摩托車載它都沒有問題可是年紀越來越大沒有辦法大家一定就會漸漸的走向一些物質化那只是說物質化的程度是高是低到時候可能就會失去一些童真
跟著
講失去童真很怪怪
反而我就是那種童年的存真
因為以孩子的角度來說
我覺得他們很特別的一點
實際上我現在跟我的兒子
有一個小小的約定
就是他只要有表現不錯的時候
我就會給他一個乖寶寶印章
我是沒有真的拿一個物理印章去蓋他
因為我也很懶
那我一下想想
我覺得我應該要去買一個印章
真的拿一個小盆奔出來蓋
但反正總之我就自己去計算
然後他自己也會去計算
他今天如果有一個不錯的表現
然後或者說他有一個很酷的表現
我不一定是想要訓練他成為
一個那種很乖人聽話的孩子
因為我覺得那是一個非常無聊的孩子
甚至腦子可能發展
沒有太好的小朋友才會非常的聽話
所以正常的小朋友應該會有一點叛逆
應該會有一些自己的想法
所以我都可以接受的
所以他獲得乖寶寶印章的一些條件
不然說像有時候在飯桌上
聽媽媽的話再是需要
因為這是有很多人一起的場合
你不希望去破壞別人的體驗
那抑或是像我們去玩滑水道的時候
我們今天是挑戰一個短的滑水道
我可能就給你三點
大的會旋轉看起來比較恐怖
速度比較快的滑水道
他非常的害怕
可是為了鼓勵他去嘗試
我可能就直接開一個非常大方的點數
我可以給你10點給你20點之類的
那一開始他會拒絕
然後甚至他會就想要抗議
但是因為他用詞還不精準
他說爸爸你在炫耀
我說這什麼是炫耀
我說我要給你20點這不是炫耀
我只是在跟你陳述一個事實
他說你這是在炫耀
因為你跟我講有這麼多點數
可是你不給我 哼你壞
但最後面他也是挑戰了自己的恐懼
在沒有人去威脅跟強迫的狀況之下
雖然有一點利誘的成分在
然後他去嘗試了滑水道
獲得了巨大的成功
下來非常的高興
我看到他成功我當然也非常的高興
然後送他這個點數
以小朋友來講他最喜歡的東西
目前其實就是寶可夢的卡包
寶可夢的卡包站在我們大人的價值觀來說
它其實是一個不便宜的東西
一個卡包特別是那種可能比較稀有的款式
搞不好就要幾百塊之類的
他用一個點數他可以換一個卡包
我就還是讓他這樣子換
但是會跟他講說可能一天最多就是幾個
可是我覺得小朋友很可愛一點
就像我剛剛前面提到說
可能學生時期還有一些那種純愛
到了學生時期之後就比較困難的原因是在於說
可能就是這樣子的一些天真跟無邪吧
他知道一點可以換卡包
可是他不會像我們去吃十套寶說
媽的我知道今天有什麼帝王蟹在那邊
我就是吃到回本
因為我已經知道每個東西價格
他們是不知道的
所以他有時候會很可愛的跟你講說爸爸你可以過來給我抱抱我要用一個點數跟你換然後或者是我可不可以用一個點數去換一球冰淇淋即便那個冰淇淋就只是我們走到隔壁的
不知道就是那種自助吧
稍微的咬一下而已
那也不用錢嘛
也不用再額外再加價的
但對他來講這些東西都是一點
卡包是一點
冰淇淋一球也是一點
甚至一個小小的巧克力球也是一點
就會覺得說這個階段真的是非常可愛
所以他並不像我們會去
有辦法識別說
這是一個很貴的度假村很爽
對來講就只是這個地方有BadSing
就是他們俄文講的游泳池
這個地方有游泳池
然後我可以曬太陽
我可以躺在那邊滑iPad
我可以有一些節節IPL玩之類的
就算你今天可能真的帶他去
像我們前面有點半開玩笑講說
帶你去親旅看
他搞不好會玩得很高興
甚至我覺得他會玩得更高興
因為你可以把窗簾拉起來
然後關在一個超小的空間
他會覺得說這就是我的城堡
這就是童真
就是他不會認為說
送去青年旅社對他是一個虐待
即便我們心中會覺得說
這個相較之下對你是虐待
但他搞不好會意外的覺得很好玩
所以仔細想想就覺得
可能我們跟小朋友相處
很快樂的一個點
就是你重新的去感受到
當年那一種
你不會去懂每個東西背後的價值怎麼樣
你只要滿足一個那種最原始的
就是想要我想要這個東西
我想要獲得一些立即的快樂
我可能在一些簡單的陪伴之下
我就可以獲得一個巨大的滿足
這個就是小朋友很可貴之處
他可以重新提醒你這樣的一些生活
這也是可能不知道
就是有些人後面在找對象
會一直想要去尋覓的
就是有些搞不好會故意裝窮之類的
他可能想要追求的就是那一種
你不是因為說你知道我有多少條件
有什麼東西
然後你才跟我在一起
而是你真心的跟我享受每一刻
即便我們今天只是騎摩托車出去繞一繞
你也覺得非常開心
你不會去嫌說
我車子的Logo一定要掛什麼
因為你可能也不一定看得懂
這可能就是每個人都去追求的一種真愛
但我還是不會覺得說
男人或是女人用物質去買斷別人
是一個不好的事
因為就算說以我來講好了
我就不是那種浪漫duke
我真的沒有辦法給你什麼情緒價值
但是有一件事情我做得很好
就是買單
所有東西我覺得都可以幫你買單
我覺得這也是一種
我們這種可能沒有那種浪漫意識
甚至有些會把它稱為說
就像鵝爛台南的幹
一點那種儀式感跟浪漫感都沒有
至少我可以做到這件事
你的浪漫duke
他可以每個東西都幫你買單嗎
不一定
所以對每個人都有不同的一個
擇偶機制
或是說類似孔雀可以去開屏
我們沒有辦法開屏
又長得不帥
又沒有那種浪漫機制
我可以好好工作賺錢
對吧 這是我的一條出路
反正總之我覺得
在這些旅遊的過程之中
然後去看著孩子的長大
然後跟他那種單純的童真
其實真的是讓自己的內心非常充足
所以雖然在養孩子的時候
有時候還是會覺得說好累或什麼
但真的一下子就會忘記
所以你聽到很多家長在跟你抱怨
好累好累的
當然不排除有些就是真的很累
他就是真的覺得養小孩子非常辛苦
可是至少在我自己
或身邊的一些朋友的觀察
大家都是很高興的
只是偶爾拿出來念一下
因為你跟大家去分享這種
親情的滿足感或什麼的
其實別人也聽不懂
聽了懂的你也不需要跟他講太多
大概就會變成這樣的一個狀態
所以稍微跟大家分享一下
接下來我們來進入商話題
最近的幾天
不管是台灣或是美國的市場
都開始出現一些回檔
最主要是集中在科技股這邊
所以外面雖然有在傳一些消息
就在說像是美債的殖利率
有些人覺得說這個就是準備要出大事了
然後再來就是就算沒有要出大事的話
當你的殖利率的數字跑到變很高
這什麼意思
代表說你可以把利率相當成是
某種地心引力
我去做一個無風險的投資
我可以拿到這樣的利率
那我為什麼要去做
相對有風險的一些股票投資
所以相對之下
它可能就會去壓縮到一些
特別是以科技股為主
就是這種可能在乘數
是相對高的股票的一個
股價的表現
或者說它的一個乘數
就會把它稍微壓下來
我覺得你可以硬去把它
作為是一種
就可能市場最近回檔的一種解釋
還OK
但我自己會覺得不太買單的一個主因
是因為其實當然我們都知道說
在7月股價跌掉很多
可是最近其實已經有蠻多股票
是回去前高了
不多 相對少數
所以蠻多就是說
就我們自己會去關注
如果說只有一兩支
那就真的蠻恐怖的
但其實有越來越多的股票
持續的去往上拉
回到前高
甚至是直接去攻新高了
所以在這樣子的一個狀況之下
你說你前面反彈這麼多幾十%
然後你稍微的往回站
可能一天跌3%
跌個2 2 3天
真的還好
就真的還好
但真的是身邊有蠻多人
都選擇去把資金大幅的往下降
可能是7月真的被嚇到一波
然後現在大家都很害怕
再來另外一個
市場上的一個算是類鬼故事
就是Walk Street Journal最近有一個報導
然後標題寫說
Why bid tax AI spending is 3 trillion higher than it seems
就是為什麼這些大科技的AI開銷
其實是有3T在水下3Tillion在水下而不是像大家看到的這些開銷我就想說你知道就是以前如果說看到這樣子的報導
在大多頭的時候
大家應該會甚至是把它當利多解釋
原來你們丟這麼多錢
供應鏈衝買
科技股衝買
一定還有很多的機會
可是就是因為可能搭配一些回檔
然後這種東西就會變得
比較像是一個鬼故事
就是說它隱含的意思是說
你以為你現在看到的支出很多嗎
你以為看到他們什麼現金流轉付
很恐怖嗎
沒有後面會怎麼樣
後面還有一堆表外的東西
就是沒有在他的資產負債表裡面的
那些未開始的租約
或是一些那種採購的承諾
所以等於說他把一些真實的槓桿率是隱藏掉了
沒有給大家看到
這其實跟黃文勳去做的一些那種
供應商融資是有一點類似
就是現在其實在場外的槓桿跟融資
他是持續的去往上做疊加
我覺得這個已經算是某個從頭上房間裡的大象
這個大象什麼時候會發作
沒有人知道
什麼時候會對市場造成破壞
但我自己的猜想
我是覺得說不會這麼快
我覺得它一定是要稍微的煮一陣子之後
然後可能才會爆炸
那等它爆炸的時候
它可能就是真的會造成一些巨大的衝擊
所以其實就像是自己身邊朋友的一些觀察
就是當你今天發現說
AI的蠻多債務
然後或者是一些投資被層層打包
做成各種投資理財的商品
或是一些
就是變成那種地方大媽
可能都可以去買到說
什麼資料中心發出來的債券
然後利率多少
保證回本啥小的
當你看到大量的產品
在市場上這樣子跑的時候
那就代表說
可能距離爆炸是已經不遠了
但是在現在這個階段
特別是還算可以明確的看到AI的變現
如果你今天去看說
anthropy的一些成績的話
當然大家會去雞蛋裡挑骨頭
那個成長率好像掉了一點
有什麼但
其實在一兩年前是很少人敢去想像說
他們可以這麼快就賺錢
所以他們已經證明說自己可以賺錢
我就覺得說不用太擔心
這一切都是一個什麼巨大的泡泡
很快會變成是泡沫
應該說哪一次的炒作
哪一次的多頭最後面
它沒有變成泡泡跟泡沫
就是一定都會
但問題是如果你想要完美去閃掉
每一個泡泡變泡沫的話
那就會變成
可能這個泡泡會吹多大你不知道吧
你沒有參與到資產的一個增長
也是蠻可惜的一件事情
所以重點應該是要放在隨著每一次的多多行情然後有辦法去把錢尻下來然后接着你就是去识别说在回挡到什么样的一个程度的时候你应该要去暂停
这个我觉得是非常重要的一件事情
那它有几个indication
一个就是说你直接去看你的回吐程度
就像这一波在7月的时候
自己是差不多就一次回了三成的
可是为什么还是会选择
继续待在场内的原因
是因为就今年是太多了
所以就算它回掉三成
對我來講還是一個我很難想像
可以在就是已經連年多頭之後
還可以獲得的一個報酬
所以我願意在市場裡面繼續等
當然我們的績效的結算方式
我們都是用年度來算
所以如果今天走到2027
就像說我今年就是只有賺2、30%
然後接著這個2、30%
可能在某一次的回檔
直接全部都被打掉的話
那我確實就是有可能會考慮
我要先去休息
即便我可能看到市场上的一些指标
都还是非常的正向
基本面的指标都还是正向
我还是会去提高警觉
因为理由是在于说
如果说股价的历史有教会我们什么事情的话
就是在每次的股价已经可能腰斩之后
我们才会知道说原来
shit hit the fan
就是已经是出大事了
已经打到电扇了
已经喷到那种整个房间都是了
一般来讲这个股价都是已经先跑了
只是當然股價先跑
你也不要太緊張的一個主因是
一個正常的多頭
本來就是漲一漲
可能會有一些回檔出來
所以我自己在這方面的做法是
我還是會去用我的一個年度表現來看
就是類似可能投信他們一些風控的做法
當然今天旗下的一些PM一些操盤
注意到說他在這個月回檔的數字太大
我就強迫你綁手
類似的道理
他可以做一個那種基礎的風控
這可能是我自己會做的
就是如果說我可能某一年的績效
一次賠掉太多
我就稍微的休息去觀望一下
即便可能外面的指標都是正向
我還是會這樣子做
再來可能我們自己想像的理想劇本
最好的劇本是
我有辦法在市場上面
我注意到一些early indication
我提早就在派對要結束前就離場
但這個其實非常困難的點就是
其實你回歸到6月
你就問你自己
6月的時候
你有沒有辦法把手上的東西丟掉
真的非常困難
我老婆6月的時候就跟我講說
要去買什麼東西
我都會跟她講說
之後再來
真的之後再來
雖然最後面我還是有乖乖的把錢掏出來
可是問題就是
在當下的感受是
我每天丟到市場裡面
你不要講說什麼YTD沒有人在看YTD都在看什麼NTD一個月賺多少甚至在看WTD一個禮拜這個禮拜賠多少你看身邊的那種投資朋友掏出來
每天就那種3%5%在漲
你怎麼可能會想要離場
所以一般來講
你就是要去做到最後一刻
然後甚至去吃到一小坡的大怒神之後
再出場
我覺得這個是很合理的
所以不要太相信外面行銷的
就是賣在高點
然後在最低點進
因為你實際經歷過幾次循環
你就知道你试一次给我看
很难真的是很难去做到这样子的事情
所以像刚才前面所提到的
这些科技巨头
可能在冰山下面
他们其实有很多带旅行的异物
这些东西都是有可能在未来的某一天
当然今天可能工需已经是拉平了
产能过剩的一个状态
虽然产能过剩有时候我觉得
就是简单讲就需求不够了
产能过剩有点讲的这种
好像是高大上
有些人可能不一定听懂
为什么产能会过剩
沒有就是需求不夠
可能過往的需求的成長速度很快
所以大家就投射了一個非常好的產能
其實也不是說這個需求整個不見
它只是拉平的
可是大家已經投下去了場
已經去融的錢
已經去買了這些設備都是要進來的
到時候就會怎麼樣
到時候就有一些痛苦要去承受
所以像2022年的修正跟回檔
事後回頭看一開始大家以為是烏二戰爭
後來當然烏二戰爭可能是一個trigger的點
但最終就是供應鏈的一個庫存調整
因為2021年的時候大家相信的是
你手上握有越多的庫存
等於你是什麼
等於你是大贏家
因為你沒有庫存的人
那種長短料配不出來的
你就是沒有辦法出貨
現在有沒有類似的道理
有點像
因為你去看美國的一些Earnings Call
每家公司都在告訴你缺到爆炸
如果說2021、2022有教會我們什麼事情的話
當你開始注意到有一些料的報價
可能已經是穩住了
它不一定是下跌
它只是穩住了
還沒有辦法上去
這時候可能就要稍微的有一點警覺
至少以現階段來講
我們所看到的各種元件
其實都還是持續維持在漲價
但是最近我自己會比較擔心的一個點是
市場上的記憶體股票
其實當然成績單
那個都是知道一定會是好的
那沒有什麼好去做爭論的
對於未來的報價
我們在過去的幾集
已經有跟大家稍微分析跟討論過
當時還有被人家砲
就是說亂講
但真的後來成績開出來
大家都知道說
我們其實是沒有亂講
有時候我們講的東西
可能不一定會很快
在市場裡面發酵
因為我們是專注去講產業
那股價
就直接承認說那個不一定
有時候就算基本面很好
也不一定會漲
因為可能過去漲很多之類的
whatever
總之就是當我們注意到說
特別是以記憶體族群
它是市場裡面最缺
並且是展望最明確的東西
如果說他們在未來的一段時間
它的股價的乘數
沒有辦法拉上去的話
我覺得這個東西就會影響到
其他components的一個市場表現
這個就是應該會有一個
很明顯的連動的效應在那邊
最主要理由就是一个最缺并且展望最明确的东西
如果它都只能在某一个PE ratio的陈述
其他人凭什么去说服市场
他们会获得一个更高的PE ratio的陈述
所以以一个大方向来说
我会觉得记忆体要持续的维持强势
可能components才会动
一样的道理如果我们今天去看
我们知道说现在在金人段的话
其实当然前段跟后段都是蛮缺的
但其实市场很多的焦点是放在后段这边
我们把它称为是一种bottleneck trade
就是你今天知道瓶颈在哪边
一个产品从它的原料到它输出成品
哪个地方的前面卡最多东西
这个东西可能就是市场上的一个重大的瓶颈
过往我们去做瓶颈的交易
是因为我们知道瓶颈就是
大家会希望立刻要去改善的东西
我们都知道说你把产能拉上去就可以改善
但问题是市场上的每个参与者
大家都知道AI的投资政行
特別是蝦也知道可以賺錢
所以每個人都希望可以快一點
讓你的東西上限
所以Time to compute是很重要的
你到底多快可以讓一個東西上限
這時候有哪些做法
第一個就是
我直接接受你的漲價
或是我用很高的價格
直接把你的產能包下來
我確保我的東西可以上
再來一些常見的做法
像NVIDIA他們就是去買一些設備
然後交給一些封裝跟測試廠
這個已經是在過往
持續的去做執行的
理由是什麼
理由是我真的讓我的供應商
去幫我做擴產的話
他們可能也不一定敢
或是他們覺得會承擔太大的風險
他們的態度會比較優異一點
我直接買設備去你那邊放
然後把利潤都談好你做不做
這個就一定會做了
所以大家會用各種方式去改善這個瓶頸
不然說像前面講的
就是他去透過漲價的方式
先把別人擠出去
或是像我們之前聊到光通的時候
也有提到說其實NVIDIA
它有去可能在我們的判斷多下了蠻多光通的元件他的目的不一定是他立刻要用到而是它想要讓它的競爭者出局讓你買不到東西兜不出去所以要去做這樣的一個嘗試
再來就是像我們要講
買一些設備進去放
這都是會發生的
所以如果今天注意到這些封裝段的東西
就在說它的股價是推不上去的話
有可能像剛剛前面講說
components段是看記憶體
在封裝段的話
這些Oset或是封裝廠
或是一些測試廠
如果你注意到在未來一段時間
他沒有辦法再往上推的話
那可能Bottleneck Trade也就暫時的休息了
因為還有什麼東西可以比這個東西更缺
所以我們會用這樣子去做一個判斷
如果說今天Component Trade
然後跟Bottleneck Trade
假設他們都去休息
我們講休息並不是說他股價一定會崩掉
可能就變還漲之類的
因為畢竟成績都還是會開出來
那就有可能會重新的去回到Value Add
也就是我到底有沒有辦法
在我晶片的迭代
或是我軟體的更新
產品的更迭之下
我真的為客戶產生了更多的價值
而不只是像component trade
比較偏像說缺貨漲價
bottleneck trade也是缺貨漲價
或是一瞬間我給你很多的需求
擴建所導致的一個受惠
value add的話
它比較偏向是
甚至有點那種無形資產的感覺
就是你也沒有辦法很明確的去講出說
它為什麼會有這個差價的存在
因為它不是單純的去趁精論量
就像我們會去吐槽說
很多人會去拆解iPhone說
它零件多少錢
為什麼它可以賣這樣
你那麼厲害你也去組一台iPhone
這個就是一個value的疊加
所以有可能市場會重新的回到value add
所以我們現在還是會蠻希望
不管是在components
或是bottleneck這邊都可以
然後持續的在市場裡面
有一些族群的輪動跟進行者
因為確實他們在後面會開成績
我們很難去想像
你的成績就像說可以開一年
但是你在一年前你的股價就漲完了
所以會比較不希望自己去受到
可能7月的一些崩跌的影響
可是確實從7月的崩跌至今
我們會很認真的去看
那到底是哪些族群要站回來
目前看起來可能比較兇的一些族群
在我看來我覺得是偏向是Value Add的這一塊
然後或者是本來可能像
我自己也會去選擇去找一些
相對有價值的東西去做Parking
可是同時我們為什麼
也會去買一些高PE ratio的東西
是因為它有一些族群性的跑出來
所以看得出來市場有去做出初步的選擇即便在這波回檔可能滿多東西都還是有打下來但這波回檔我覺得就是一個非常關鍵如果說當然它沒有更加的惡化破底往下撞的話
它回檔之後再繼續去攻破
這波回檔前面的高點的一些族群
不管你是哪一個sector
或是說前面我們講的哪一種trade
不管是components或是bottleneck
然後或者是value add
誰先走出去的話
應該就會定調
假設多頭還存在的話
下一個主流族群
在現在看就會變得是相對的明朗
所以會覺得這個盤之所以
像身邊很多朋友覺得不舒服
或是選擇接馬
但我自己還好的一個最核心的理由是
我覺得像在7月這樣子回到了三層
這個其實是2022年的一個回檔了
為什麼我們感覺還是有辦法
可以談笑風聲
是因為今年上半年非常好
所以你就只是獲利一個回途而已
可是如果今天是在2022年的話
那時候你等於從年初
你就是一路在賠錢
所以你就真的會覺得體感非常的不對勁
你的一些策略也會這樣子去做調整
現在之所以沒有去做調整
就是因為可能大家在上半年的表現都還很好
重點是在這一波修正之後
本來我自己的想像是要等到年底
就是可能至少第四季才可以去收復
因為你很難想像說你知道你回掉三成
然後你要再爬回去的話
你就1除以0.7
你就會知道其實你要回去
你並不是要往上爬三成
因為你爬三成的話你只有0.91
你還是沒有到1
你要回很多才可以爬上去
但我還是非常感謝8月至今的行情
雖然最近又出現了一些那種小天法
但至少8月這波真的回超級快
不管是台灣的指數貴買
然後或者說美股的科技相關的指標
所以就會覺得只要它回的夠快
那就沒有太大的問題
就不會再去做那種額外的擔心或是遐想
然後選擇把它不會砍掉
因為我本來的預設是
我要第四季才可以開始收復石土
沒有想到我在8月可能就已經收復失土一半
這個是超出自己的一個預期
所以你去吃這些回檔
其實也會覺得說心裡是蠻踏實的
但當然我們也不是說就是無腦多
就還是會再去做一些觀察
所以像前面先把市場的族群
先簡單拆分成為三塊
那components這邊
除了我們去盯期一體之外
再來就是相信大家也多少知道
不然說我們節目前面有跟大家說
就是後面會有一些dispack的狀況出來
即便我們有去說明
這個dispack的原因只是因為
他們想要去更加友善的去改善供應就覺得說我今天如果要去做12high 16high的話良率低嘛然後產出少嘛那有沒有可能我就稍微的我不要這麼高的跌層
我要的是頻寬
我不一定要去拼容量
我可以用科數去拼容量
所以他去做dispack
那這個就是有可能也會
在市場裡面去造成一些動盪跟衝擊
就即便你可能喊破喉嚨跟大家說
這個還是一個長多的故事
但有些人光是聽到這一段
他就不想要了
或者說他可能本來想去做一些components
可是他看到市場上最缺的components
都沒有辦法漲
那我幹嘛要去做其他
雖然也很缺
但是沒有像那個東西這麼缺的一個components
這個可能是後面比較抽象的一段
但是是需要去做理解的
那也稍微跟大家分享最近的一些心得
所以簡單來講就是
我覺得雖然這波的修正看起來也是蠻恐怖的
但是因為前面調很深
那彈超多
所以他只要修正
簡單來說就是在這邊沒有那種加速往下
轉開始橫開始正的話
反而是要去找機會
去找可能前面我們把它拆解之後
看有沒有什麼那種新的族群跑出來
去找那個族群可能會是一個
蠻不錯的一個方向
好 接下來我們就來進入QA的部分
第一位
李歐打到雷指標
哈囉 夢宮Chika
想問你以前玩風之谷的時候
有沒有打到過黃色雨傘
打了多久才打到
最近看到一個YouTuber阿銀仔
打了45個小時才打到黃傘
不曉得Chika會不會覺得
他是個臭衰鬼
希望你可以用酸民的語氣對阿銀仔說
你是熊阿銀仔準備打2000小時的赤龍啦
200小時的赤龍啦
祝平安愉快
對了諾亞會對Oksana說阿婆飛機嗎
那個Babla飛機的故事應該是已經是幾年前了
就他還是小朋友的時候
然後他就覺得他的Babla很煩
就是看他一直要弄他
所以他就覺得希望他快點離開
就整天這個Babla飛機
叫他趕快坐飛機離開
現在不會啦現在長大了啦
其實跟他的不管是我爸爸這邊的
或是說我老婆那邊的長輩
都還是玩得蠻開心的
大家也都很樂意跟他玩
所以他不會想叫大家離開
他反而是希望大家都留下
然後再講說有沒有打過黃色雨傘
我以前是沒有在玩風之谷
只有稍微的可能朋友推坑摸一下
也並沒有很認真的玩他
以前是會去打那個什麼
魔獸世界有一個在寒冰地圖
忘記那個地圖叫什麼
但裡面有一隻時光流氏圓龍
就是你要騎著龍在上面等
騎著你的座騎在上面等
然後他可能就是幾個小時才會出一次
就一堆人在那邊蹲點
我也是不知道打了他媽的幾十
還是上百個小時
然後才終於蹲到他
那時候還要裝什麼警報
其實仔細想想以前在玩線上遊戲的時候
真的蠻瘋狂的
跟上班一樣
工會要打
大家都要上線
打罵好幾個小時
喝提升飲料
晚上再網咖睡覺之類的
其實現在真的沒有辦法做這些東西
所以我現在其實是蠻喜歡一些遊戲
那種pay to win的機制
雖然我知道蠻多玩家很討厭
但只能夠說可能年紀大了
你就會開始理解
如果我可以用一些錢去買練功的時間
或是一些裝備
我幹嘛不買
有病了
我上班就很累了
我怎麼可能還像年輕的時候
整天骂赖在网咖里面打
就不太可能
但那是一种那种年轻的浪漫
下面一位太长调过
下面一位
马亦龙孟公安
当初是为了生活品质
才进到没什么钱的美光
没有想到近两年产能满载
每天累了跟狗一样
想说既然没有生活
至少工作的报酬可以高一点
没有想到高层在这种
记忆体风转的时候说
营收跟你们的分红没有关系
分红远低于同产业的标准
括号少10到60倍
亏钱的时候由员工承担被裁员
分红归零零条新的后果
那近期开始思考
这种公司我们是否要持续的待下去
但同时我非常喜欢部门的同事跟主管
去到其他公司又要重新抽同事跟主管
那想问一下梦工大
你会选好公司烂部门还是烂公司好部门
美光有很小气吗
我是没有更新到最近的
可是因为我身边有一些朋友在美光
我记得前阵子不是发的蛮大方的吗
还说后来怎么
還說什麼你們是可能去跟韓國抗爭之後的比較
我不曉得
但應該是沒有道理太小氣
特別是其實我們最近看一些
那種缺料漲價相關的公司
其實蠻多人都拿很多錢
甚至是一些那種系統廠ODM
哇靠他們拿的那個package
甚至會去擊敗以前
就是大家講的什麼豬食屋
或者說神山之類的
那個是真的還蠻嚇人的
所以我不太確定
當然這個可能不知道
一家公司裡面每個人分紅的數字高跟低
我也不曉得
但有這麼誇張嗎?我不知道
然後再來講說
是會去選好公司爛部門
還是爛公司好部門
我覺得你不用想這麼多
簡單講說錢給到位什麼都不是問題
你出去工作你會感覺到委屈
絕大多數
這是馬雲還是誰講的嗎
然後就說你就是錢沒有給到位
這個我認為是非常真實的一個陳述
你錢給我超級多
就算你去叫我做一個死缺
我都有可能會接受
但是你錢給我少
就算是一個我的夢想工作我都不一定會去做因為錢真的太少了大家出來工作不是來交朋友的進去上班我們是一家人誰跟你他媽是一家人
我們不是一家人
如果我們是一家人
那我告訴你
我今天還去了另外一個
什麼劉家 陳家 王家 皇家
我都去做面試了
每個都跟我說一家人
到底我是哪一家
不用去信這些東西
反正就是錢給到位就沒有問題
如果真的硬要去這兩個二選一的話
這很奇怪
我知道有些人會有一些那種企業認同感
他覺得這家公司很酷
聽起來很有名氣
500大
家人會喜歡
那你進去做一個超級死缺錢很少
他也覺得予有榮焉
因為我是這個單位的
你有這種情節的話
你當然就是選前者
但以我來說
如果這兩個真的要選的話
我會選好部門
至少大家的氣氛是對的
即便公司可能你跟人家講
都沒有聽過
這可能要Google查一下
Google可能還查不到
那也不是特別重要的事情
至少我是快樂的
所以如果這件事情是單純的在講說
名聲或是說名氣的話
後者啦
我覺得我管公司的名氣大不大
但其實最終還是直接回去講
錢是最快的啦
所以當覺得今天錢是委屈了
那並且你知道你換到另外一邊
就有立刻有更好的錢
那他是一個權衡標準
就算說他如果只多10%的錢
你可能就不想放棄你的同事
那我就問你
那如果多100%的錢你不要放棄
立刻放棄誰不會放棄
差不多就是這樣的道理
那下面一位
我這一生如履薄冰
你說你愛的不該愛的人
不知道他那個
你說我們想接這個
猛工有看凡修仙逆玲瓏這類的路漫嗎
真心覺得這幾年中國動畫技術越做越好
尤其是最近心上的牛來推薦猛工看看
新聞有看到
像是一個低成本製作
然後意外賺很多錢的東西
然後說另外想請教猛工在產業面的資訊
都從哪裡吸收
是純文字還是有土象剖析的
沒有看實體實在是很難想像
像你上一集提到規格提升
就可以馬上行為流水的接續
Busbar的截面會變大
Cable重量跟彎曲的半徑會變大
Connector的尺寸跟插拔力的改變
你也說自己不是電的專家
但你依然可以在沒有完整拼圖的情況下
自己摸到那麼深
我也想成為像你一樣的產業池漢
以及沒有升量優勢的一般散戶
要如何去東拼西湊外
還能夠修正錯誤
感恩愛您
為什麼我會知道Busbar的截面會變大
我也知道Busbar這個元件
最早是因為當年有一個
Stealth Company
就是去做immersion cooling的
然後他們為了要去解決Buzz Bar
花了很多時間所以當時的裡面的產業的朋友就是跟我去很詳述這些Buzz Bar的差別每家公司可以給的材料然後跟尺寸的狀況怎麼樣
所以我第一次很認真的去研究這個東西是什麼
然後再講說Cable為什麼會知道
因為在投資貿連的時候
就要去了解每一條Cable
每條線是要幹嘛
甚至到最後面是已經知道說
反正你看到某個顏色的線
那個就是貿連的東西
所以你今天去看展看到說
後面都是某個顏色的線
回去立刻買股票
買股票 這是開玩笑的
但你就會知道說那個是他的
那為什麼你會知道
因為你去研究這家公司
所以你會知道說
他會跟你提到這個Cable會怎麼樣去做
裡面要不要再額外放一個什麼訊號源
或者說這個銅線
或者說淚光的一個解方
什麼時候會進來什麼時候會出去
你都是有辦法在一些法說會
或是公開資料去找到
再來講說Connector的話
就是你今天如果去研究一些Socket公司
或是一些Plugable的元件
你就會去了解到這個東西的應用
然後或是相關的變化
就像說像以前Socket
你也是覺得說
不就是像那種電腦上面一些Socket
就是我這邊一直插拔
也插拔沒有關係
可是後來研究到Anthony之後
然後你再看了幾個電話會議
或是甚至一些同業的互相吐槽
你就會去明白
原來這個東西
像最早的那些AI伺服器
它這個插拔可能
插拔五次之後東西就壞掉了
那它怎麼樣做
它就是可能在測試的時候
我就不要插拔這麼多次
反正是用那種很北欄的方式
反正測試先過
然後後面再看怎麼樣
但你就知道說
原來這個東西也會在插拔的過程中
因為它裡面的針太多了
就會去造成一些良率上的問題
所以簡單來講說這些東西它都不是
我可能看完回答的800V報告
然後我就知道這些東西
沒有它都是過往的養分的累積跟堆疊
因為我看過這些東西
其實最會發現說這些科技電子相關的東西
它都會有一個底層邏輯在背後
就來說可能大家的目標都會是去追求萎縮
這是一個在那種比較尖端科技
可能大家會去做的
可是如果今天成熟科技的話
大家因為沒有空間的一個迫切的需要
跟知道這個空間很值錢的一個條件在的話
我可能要追求什麼就是穩定度
所以我就不會去追求我的東西要
從可能不知道28、16然後走到85、32奈米
或是做什麼AS6、AS4
我沒有必要嘛
我可能就持續的用成熟製程的東西
或是一些特殊製程的東西
因為我車子的容量這麼大
對不對我裡面多塞幾顆晶片
所以你會注意到車子跟可能一些伺服器
或者說手機PC筆電它的邏輯就不太一樣但是當你懂手機PC筆電邏輯你再去推可能伺服器然後或者說後來的AI伺服器有點像那種一路通路路通
就以前我們打LOL一樣
就是當你知道Jungle要怎麼樣Gank
就算我今天給你不同的角色
那你還是可以很快的上手會Gank
你只要把這個角色的它的豬源
叫做QWE分別是幹嘛
你要搞清楚
可是邏輯是一樣的
哪邊可以蹲草
什麼時候要出來
什麼時候要叫隊友要幹嘛
那個是差不多的
所以最難的就是一開始
因為你什麼都還不知道的時候
你真的會花非常多的時間
可是當你今天
就像說你可以去了解手機之後
然後你再去看PC
當然它有一定程度的差距
只是也沒有差這麼多
你看裡面都一樣Wi-Fi晶片
可能一樣會有觸控
然後再來會有一個Display
然後再來電源裡面的PIMM
它其實都是類似的元件
去做排列組合
然後應用不一樣
所以你今天懂一個
你就會更容易的去懂另外一個東西
所以差不多這樣子
我覺得你就是用那種跳島這樣慢慢過去
所以這個其實並不需要你有升量的優勢
升量的優勢沒有辦法幫你做好這些功課
這些其實都是要你自己來的
升量的優勢在於說
你在獲得一些消息或是一些產業認知的時候
你的速度可以比別人快
就像說像我們年初的時候知道衛星的狀況好
那為什麼知道
那就是簡單講升量優勢
沒有升量優勢你不會知道
然後再來就是
你要怎麼樣知道說一些元件會漲價
而且你講的時候可能沒有人相信
因為大家看不到
可是後面大家就看到了
然後就知道了
所以前面可能有些還會
甚至會笑你會罵你
然後他們只是後製後裙而已
這個就是聲量有史
但聲量有史沒有辦法
幫你把前面的這種
聲根要根源的東西做好
所以它是有差距的
我覺得那是需要一點時間去做累積的
那大概這樣
下面一位
哈魯蒙公老公可以對我的8月份生日
健身教练Vamosfit的Jan说那四个字吗
谢谢老师很快乐
下面一位Lan
Aida您好
我是潜水的中时听众
有医疗相关的专业证照
最近出国学英文回来
有意申请国外的学校
所以想要先跨出舒适圈
找跟英文相关的工作
不过稍微爬了一些外商跟科技业
好像很少相关的工作
目前开放的职缺大多要求一定的学经历
不确定是否我找的方向错误
希望Aida跟观音大
可以指点迷津产业别不限
希望是能夠頻繁接觸英文的工作
小女感激不盡
不知道怎麼我覺得你的需求很奇怪
你是醫療相關證照
然後跑去學英文之後
回來又想要再繼續學英文
只為了要去申請
申請國外的學校
你不是就已經跑去學英文了嗎
還是說你的意思是說
你現在學英文不夠
你還想再加強
可是為什麼你要去上班
因為你去上班的話
你應該是會花蠻多時間處理
跟英文沒有相關的東西
如果說你真的想要一直去講英文的話
你可能反而是要去找一些
就要做一些那種打工度假
然後去做那種最基層的服務生
你有可能就會必須要一直開口
你要跟客人講話
可是那可能也是聚焦在一些
就是你的工作所需要的用語
跟訓練你的勇氣
可能是蠻好用
但是對你的智慧或是你的表達
不一定會去造成一個長足的影響
那我覺得現在就是AI時代
你直接做一個最簡單
你現在去下載任何一家的AI模型
我覺得都沒有問題
非常的簡單
因為這個功能是那種entry level的
語言是最簡單的
你抓下來之後
你就開啟它的語音模式
然後接著你就跟它說
你想要學英文
你想要它跟你對話
你就一直跟這個AI對話
其實我覺得可能會比去補習
去找班上或者是去幹嘛
都來得更加的有效
AI對語言的訓練或是一些那種
數理簡單的訓練
我覺得是非常強大
它可以相當有效的去取代一些家教
當然如果你還是希望說跟人家面對面
因為你想要順便培養勇氣
跟人家開口的一個實力的話
去找個家教可能也有效
我覺得工作反而是一個
效率沒有這麼好的東西
然後再來就是老闆的角度
就是說殺小老子付你錢
不是要讓你在學英文的
所以你進去
你還是會花很多時間去學專業技能
然後可能才會去做到
你講這個英文的應用
但他就是有點脫褲子放屁
除非說你想要再順便賺一點錢
所以我覺得直接找AI可能是最快的
下面一位
KXX畢業班的叔叔真的會笑死
沒什麼料只能夠靠麥克賣App賺錢
還硬要放很噁的大頭照看一次監舉一次
根本不知道這位在講誰
下面一位
靖出位安安沒有什麼問題要問
只是想說我曾經也是從業10年以上的遊戲開發人員
但礙於當年台灣的業界環境不是這麼理想
所以離開了
聽到你對紅顏路比的上市心得
覺得有點感動
有點想起當初幾次產品上線的那種心情
既複雜又興奮的感覺
對開發人員來說
能夠好好完成一個自己喜歡的作品
真的就已經很不容易了
一般人只看得到成敗
但成敗的因素太多
其中能夠透過校男資本這樣的外語言
來克服各種問題
也是以前都不敢想的事情
主委真的是做慈善
願稱你為林口好人好事代表
那最後祝主委全家平安順心
原本想說希望各位聽眾平安度過這波行情
但一直沒有留言成功到現在市場氣氛好像已經恢復了改成希望韓國人別做股票好了這個希望蠻不錯他們真的是金融恐怖分子真的是你從以前
就是縱觀到現在
就知道韓國人進去瘋狂的東西
後面真的都會出事情
然後把大家一起炸掉
再來講說
像是在做慈善
沒有啦
我不希望去講說我們是在做慈善
因為做慈善就是說你會沒有回報
也不是說我們希望在遊戲裡面獲得回報
但我們的目標是
我們的目標還是希望去
某個程度上的證明
其實在台灣是有很多很棒的團隊
很棒的軟體開發人員
如果說你給他們他們要的資源
就是像我們現在在做的事情
並且像那個紅顏露比的八哥
我非常感謝他有發一篇文
也有感謝到我們
然後提到說我們是最棒的一個經援
因為我們進來之後
我們沒有再跟他廢話的
也不會去跟他指導說他一定要怎麼樣
反正我們就滴滴做好之後
我們就相信你之數
就是這樣
就跟那種日本國中生一樣
非常熱血的動漫場景
我們是相信說遊戲一定是比我們會做
這是肯定的
但是我們也相信我們自己的眼光
所以投下去之後我們希望有好事發生
如果真的成功證明的話
是不是就代表說
大家不會再講說在台灣開發遊戲是自殺
是什麼把你的
Azo留給你的遺產亂花掉
是真的可以賺錢的
是不是就會有更多年輕人想來做這件事情
是不是就會有更多的資本
他知道可以賺錢嗎
他就會進來
因為以前沒有辦法去定價
你要跟我講說
投資遊戲可以賺錢
媽你要嘛是詐騙
要嘛就是我不知道
你想要在我身上去拐一些東西之類
就沒有人相信
我們在做的時候
一開始也是蠻多網友的指教
他們沒有惡意
其實絕大多數人都是站在
那種比較正面的立場
但他們還是不免的說
希望他們成功
看起來就是一定會爆掉
一定會失敗
但至少我們家第一款遊戲
是蠻成功的
我們希望後面都可以持續打出
成功的戰役
那也希望可以遇到年輕版本的鏡
當然現在遇到你也是很棒
那我意思是說就是
像你當時非常熱血想做的時候
可是你注意到業界裡面缺乏了一些資源
那我們來熱業
所以年輕的鏡就會知道說
他有可能可以找到資源
這邊稍微講一下
因為確實有蠻多人一直寫信來
希望我們可以去投資他某什麼的
其實我們都有看到信
我們不會每一封信都回
只能夠說還沒有回你
或是說你沒有收到信的
就是實際未到
我們就實際未到
我們會去做一些判斷
我們裡面其實有蠻多
簡單講說雖然我們前面講得非常的大方非常的衝那種日本漫畫但我們都是非常聰明非常機敏的人我們知道什麼時候去幫助一些人可以把他推到他要的地方去
我們也不是說什麼
只會去救那些可能已經是很好
或是很頂尖的團隊
很多我們去加入的團隊
他們當下是可能不一定發出薪水
或是很慘的
所以我們不會去用一些那種
等於說直打順風牌
特別是在遊戲市場
你說台灣真的有多少遜風牌
沒有我們就進來打逆風牌的
但就是希望可以證明給大家看
證明給大家看不是說什麼
讓大家知道說你好棒喔
讚是
就是真的希望可以把這個做起來
因為我們從小都喜歡打遊戲
我們一定會希望說台灣有很多很棒的遊戲
下面一位
電腦不要當機拜託
嗨寶貝夢宮
今年來聽節目真的學到很多
有個問題要請教
自己努力試著做好基本面分析
但同樣都是完整的研究公司
又分成研究品質好的跟研究品質爛的
想問夢宮要研究到什麼程度
一年的標準才OK
因为身边没有人可以交流基本面的想法
且身旁能够接触到的资源周梦公司最强的
许愿用一家公司做举例
要研究到什么程度在你的认知中才算是OK
举例这家公司之后
我学习后才能够多次复制到多少公司
多个公司
目前我的能力为读年报季报
劝报法说会资料
弄财务模型拆PQ弄出EPS
但产业上怎么弄到财务模型上不太知道
以及通常你是怎么做研究的
这边其实也不用特地去举某一家公司
就直接用你的说法来做
对你研读的资料非常的棒
那再来你的财务模型去拆PQ的话
除非说你是有把年报的各个类别都有拆出来看
不然你的PQ可能是说
就是整家公司的Average Sell Price ASP
那这可能不一定会是我们想要追求的一个东西
为什么
一家公司他可能做的东西非常多
据来说像我最近有在做的一家公司
那他可能本來有蠻多的業務
是偏向說是傳統的consumer PC
只是他現在可能去做了一個
光通插拔的東西
那這個東西有可能是
後面市場上可能可以賺很多錢的東西
可是如果你用過往的東西去研究
你是沒有辦法獲得這一段資訊的
那這時候要怎麼辦
你就要有辦法知道說
那一個元件它的單價是多少
那當這個元件進來貢獻多少量之後
它可以造成的
公司的毛利跟獲利的上修是多少
但關鍵的參數是什麼
就你要知道這個原件價格多少
那你就去參加一下法術會
說不定人家會告訴你
如果人家不告訴你的話
那你可能可以去參照一下歐美同業他們可能在電話會議裡面一般上下游之間或者說同業之間可能都會有一些訊號去暗示你說這個東西可以提升多少就像說他會說這個東西跟我傳統的東西比
他可能在毛利是多了幾個百分點之類的
他不會講得很具細謎
但會告訴你說會是怎麼樣
然後再來就是他可能會跟你提到一些線索
可能這個產品的成長
會對我們公司某一個sector的營收
造成多少的一個貢獻
可是這個東西明明就是一個
可能相對小的東西
為什麼它可以去造成這樣子的貢獻
要嘛就是說他單價非常高
要嘛就是說他量是出的非常多
所以你就可以有辦法獲得
更加詳細的一些數字去做推敲
所以這樣子應該來說
就可以去交出一個蠻不錯的報告
但重點來其實並不是說什麼
分成研究品質好的跟研究品質爛的
就有辦法在你的投資績效
造成一些幫助
不一定
就是有很多是很好的研究報告
但他研究到了一家不會漲的公司
這是非常現實的
就是你很會研究沒錯
但是巧富難為五米之催
你給他一坨垃圾
他研究了半天就不會漲
不會漲就是沒有用
所以你要去抓到產業的好東西去做研究
就算你的研究的結果很爛
你還是會賺錢
為什麼我們不知道去吐槽我們的投資同業
或是身邊的朋友
但確實是我們很常看到的一個現象是
每次當有一個題材出現
市場一定會overshoot
什麼意思
大家亂估就是亂估一些素子
就像現在有一些公司
我們知道說後段太滿了怎麼辦
外包出去
每個可能接到外包的公司
都會聲稱說
他可以在裡面獲得多少的收益
可是如果你站在一個更高角度看
就會知道說
憑什麼這麼多人在競爭
為什麼這個
就像說TAM這麼大
你就是分到這個share
你不應該是分到這個share
但是如果你要去炒這家公司的話
你就注意到有蠻多的研究報告
就會把
就像說他獲得的share
然後跟ASP可能都會去高估
我不確定是不是故意的
但一定有很多是故意的
因為就是要拱這個股票
他要把EPS喊著震天價想之類
但你說這是一個垃圾報告
如果你用純產業面的角度
你會說幹亂估
所以等於你給他一個thumbs down
一個不好的評價
但問題就是你買了還是會漲
還是會賺錢
有人愛有人瘋狂到上修就會上去
所以你到底該怎麼樣評價
一個報告是好的報告還是爛的報告
有一個報告看起來那種破破的
可是他有抓到重點
即便他數字估錯
錯的亂七八糟
賺錢就是一個好的報告
在我的角度是這樣
除非我今天是單純的
去走一個科普的路
〔此段辨識失敗，約 50:00 起〕